et si ce tableau où cette photo prenez
place temporairement dans votre salon
dans la salle de réunion de votre
entreprise
artaud cher une association étudiants de
l'ue vs qu vient de lancer un service de
location d'oeuvres d'art sa mission
démocratiser l'art contemporain le but
du coup c'est vraiment de mettre l'art
au coeur du quotidien des étudiants mais
aussi des habitants de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines et plus largement
des entreprises puisque notre but c'est
aussi de les toucher
cette artothèque s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un projet d'étudiants de master en
management des organisations culturelles
et artistiques
elle est hébergée au rez-de-chaussée de
la bibliothèque universitaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
notre rôle consiste surtout à les aider
à pouvoir rencontrer un public et donc
pour ça leur mettre à disposition un
local travailler avec eux pour des
règles de prêt pour une organisation
administrative qui puisse rendre
possible le prêt et la vente des oeuvres
qu'ils n'ont qui ne présentent que l'on
soit étudiant particulier ou une
entreprise
le tarif de location de retards varient
entre 10 et 1200 euros
au total une vingtaine d'artistes
contemporains de la région ont collaboré
pour enrichir le catalogue on emprunte
bien des livres alors pourquoi ne pas
emprunter des oeuvres je trouve ça c'est
un biais qui est complémentaire à celui
de la visite muséal ou d'expositions ou
même de l'achat moi j'ai choisi un grand
politique en cinq pièces et je les
choisis parce que je me suis dit aussi
qu'il pourrait être loué en une deux
trois quatre ou cinq pièces selon les
espaces on voudrait le maître espace de
découvertes de rencontres et de partage
l'artothèque est ouverte tous les
mercredis et samedis de 13h à 16h